hello and welcome to a new edition
of las vegas lawenda spanish cheers to
natalia bad sound today we start
talking about pancho barraza and it is that the
mexican singer will bring his 30th
anniversary tour to the stage from later
within the plan the hardware this
september 11 tickets for  tonight and they
are on sale there was ticketmaster.com
we make a change of musical genre and
we go to rock and roll and that is that the
legendary semi higher must generate has
been named as the new
musical resident of scratch the show is happy for me
and friends and  mujer son friends will feature
a cast of different artists
who will take turns
rather taking the stage with the first
show starting on
Halloween weekend well and the circus is back
but not just any circus is telling you about
the iconic dream of  His king this week
, due to the anticipated return of the coach, returned
to the treasure island stage after a
break of more than a year due to the
pandemic.  unique experience that is my
existence is presented from Friday to Tuesday
that would be the first cirque du
soleil show and return to
afp
[Music]
well the next show to make its
return is at the bellagio starting on the
first of July michael jackson one
loud  and viruses take the stage in
August, while here in the gameplay it will
be presented this fall,
well, speaking of the Bellagio, its buffet
will reopen its doors seven
days a week starting on Friday
, July 16. Its opening hours are from
7 a.m.  am to 3 pm
ok and now let's talk about
the independence day festivities for this
weekend
sterling's annual patriotic parade returns this year
with hosts from las vegas now 6 and
mercedes and hosts from news now
service johns  and brian love test the
festivities will take effect on july 3
between the summer link spark at 9 in
the morning
well and for the first time the vice sees and
is organizing a fireworks
show  official to celebrate
independence day this will be performed by the
same people who are in charge of the
new year show so you already
know that this will be a must the
fireworks will be launched throughout the
7 casinos in the south starting at 11
at night that another day than the 4th of
July and for those freaks in
town it will also be hosting a
fireworks extravaganza this
weekend this will light up the sky from
four different points in town
one at green valley ranch investor
lake  las vegas or lake las vegas and
gallery at sunset the fun starts
at 9pm on the 4th of july for
a complete list of all
the independence day events you can
visit news now dotcom ok and that's as far as it
went saying las vegas  ' I swim
in Spanish thank you very much for your
health care to Natalia bad
sound see you next week
[Music]